[Musique]
elle les principaux résultats sport du
week-end avec mickaël millero bonsoir
bonsoir analystes aux sports de la
rédaction de tv 78 du rugby pour
commencer avec le championnat de
fédérale 3 un choc au programme de la
14e journée
versailles recevait à bobigny au stade
de porchefontaine deux équipes au coude
à coude dans la course au top 4 en fin
de saison
malmenés en début de match les versets y
concède rapidement des points sont menés
13 à 0 au bout de 22 minutes de jeu les
bleus arrivent à revenir dans la partie
avec un drop inscrit le score à la pause
13 à 3 en seconde période versailles
pousse à la faute les joueurs de bobigny
les joueurs de la cité royale marque un
essai les versets y reviennent à hauteur
et marquent cette nouvelle pénalité dans
les toutes dernières minutes du match
score final 16 à 13 pour versailles on
écoute la réaction du coach les gars ont
du coeur ils ont trouvé les solutions et
avec du mouvement et l'intensité on a
réussi à passer devant sur la fin de
match
versailles est désormais un troisième
avec 41 points et peut rêver plus grand
et pourquoi pas une qualification en
phase finale en fin de saison du
handball pour continuer le championnat
de nationale 3 et là aussi une victoire
oui mais cette victoire a eu également
un peu de mal à se dessiner pour les
jaune et noir de plaisir les joueurs
devaient impérativement battre
thionville à domicile ce samedi 25
janvier pour s'éloigner de la zone de
relégation
ce match commence pourtant mal pour les
locaux les visiteurs mènent rapidement 9
à 6 face à des plaisirs oise sans
solution en deuxième période plaisir
accélère et se détachent les joueurs
comptent jusqu'à dix buts d'avancé après
15 minutes de jeu
thionville ne reviendra pas ce qu'en
finale 30 à 24 il écoute la réaction du
capitaine benjamin ball est en fait du
bien d'avoir d'avoir les trois points
parce que c'était l'objectif
en gagnant ce match on leur passe devant
au classement et ça niveau comptable ça
fait vraiment du bien donc final la
manière passer en second plan et on voit
qu'on fait une excellente deuxième mi
temps
et voilà pour la finalité c'est bien
pour le couple 1 au classement un
plaisir est aujourd'hui huitième avec un
point de plus que son adversaire du jour
et s'éloigne de la zone de relégation
prochain match pour confirmer ce samedi
à 1er février contre villemomble
toujours à domicile merci michael on
vous retrouve bien sûr pour d'autres
résultats dans votre émission le cetud
sport après ce journal